-Ooh, you look good.
I love this.
-Hey, you like that?
-The mustache, yes!
-This is for the play.
-Wow.
-But we darken it a little bit
for the play.
-You colored the --
You colored the 'stache?
-I color it for the play.
Now it's kind of -- it's ginger.
I'm a little ginger there.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, I like it.
-You know, for theater,
you want it to kind of pop.
-Because you are more of, like,
a brown, I would say,
like a brown-haired man.
-Yeah, kind of brown,
yeah, light brown.
But then, the facial hair
is kind of...
-More ginger.
-...ginger, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I always wanted to be, like,
Italian as a young actor,
so I would --
You know, Robert de Niro,
whatever.
Won't be in a Scorsese movie.
So I'd darken it in.
For auditions,
I'd get newspaper print
and put it on my face
to get that sort of Don Johnson,
swarthy, kind of...
-Is that real?
-Yeah.
-And did it ever --
-It worked, yeah.
It makes you look kind of like,
you know, rugged.
-Five o'clock shadow.
-Yeah.
-I would totally do that.
[ Laughter ]
-It works.
-And you got the roles?
-And now we have make-up
to do that.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-But rubbing newspaper on it
is actually -- I enjoy that.
-A little trick.
A little trick.
-I want to talk about
"American Buffalo."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, man.
Thanks for having me.
-Because this is --
Oh, come on.
You know we love you, man.
I don't know what I'd do
without Sam Rockwell.
Man, I love you buddy, come on.
But this play was supposed
to be -- is it two years ago?
-This is supposed to be
two years ago.
Were shut down at the very
beginning of lockdown, pandemic.
-Is that tough?
-It was very tough.
It was kind of heartbreaking.
Of course, we thought
it would be over
in two weeks, a month.
And so Fishburne and I
continued to run lines
on FaceTime and Zooms,
and occasionally
Neil, the director, and Darren
would join.
And we just did it because
we were losing our minds.
-Yeah, "This will be over
in a month.
This will be over."
-Yeah, and sometimes,
even three times a week,
we'd run lines.
But, also, just to keep
our sanity, I think.
-Just to entertain yourself.
-Exactly, yeah.
-During the lockdown, yeah.
-During the lockdown.
-Can you set up
what the play is about?
It take place in a pawnshop.
-It's in a pawnshop.
All these guys are either
thieves, junkies,
or ex-convicts, and they're --
they're all trying to get this
American Buffalo nickel,
with also maybe hopes of having
a lot of other valuable nickels
to make a lot of money.
-Yeah.
-That's what the play is about.
It's kind of like "Seinfeld"...
[ Laughter ]
...but stealing.
-Yeah, yeah, okay, yeah.
But this is --
Your character, Teach...
-Yes, yes.
-Teach is the character.
Before this had been played
by Al Pacino, Robert Duvall,
Dustin Hoffman.
-That's right.
Did they have a mustache?
I don't think so.
-I don't think so.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think so.
[ Both laugh ]
Would you get nervous
if any of them came?
-Oh, yeah, I would be
very nervous, yeah.
I did "Fool for Love,"
and Ed Harris originated
that role,
and I would have nightmares
because I used to do
the lasso with that
and nail objects with a --
And I had nightmares
that Ed Harris would see me
lasso really badly.
And actually, he came,
and it went pretty well.
I lassoed good that night.
Thank God.
-He didn't stand up
and point at you and laugh?
[ Laughter ]
-In my dreams.
-Yeah.
-In my nightmares he did.
-He would do that.
-Yeah.
-But in real life, no.
Ed Harris, pretty good guy.
-He was a good guy.
No, it was great.
-I've seen you on Broadway
and act.
-You've seen me on the Broadway.
-I've seen you on the Broadway.
-Yes, yes.
-But does it bum you out
when you have friends
in the crowd?
-I don't like to know
when people are out there.
-Really?
-I think Fishburne
and Darren don't mind.
-Because why? Do you try
to put too much mustard on it?
-Yeah, exactly, exactly.
-You try to show me your chops
too much, I go,
"Sam, you're good, buddy."
-"Hey, calm down."
-You got the Oscar, bud,
we're good.
I know how good you are.
You don't have to teach me.
-Dude, relax.
-Jimmy Fallon, man, that's good.
And you're like,
"Jimmy, sit down."
You're not bothering me.
It's Ed Harris is bothering me.
I don't care if you're here,
buddy."
But I don't know --
-No, that would make me nervous
if you were there,
you and Nancy.
-I don't know if I would
come back to see you.
Is that rude?
-No. You know what?
That's actually not rude.
I think it's actually good.
Let the actors, you know --
-Wonder.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-If I enjoyed it.
-But also, just, like,
just let them go to bed.
You know, you don't have to --
-That's what I'm saying.
-I just go --
you just performed for me,
amazing for an hour and a half.
-Then you got to do like
a backstage talk show.
-Yeah. "Hey, do you mind, Sam,
can I get a selfie?"
And you go, "Yeah, Jimmy,
I can, but I just
entertained you
for two hours, bud."
But I feel bad.
-You want to go to sleep
after you do this, right?
You want to go to bed.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And you know it so well,
you're like, "I'm in the zone"?
-I never feel on cruise control
with this thing.
I always feel like, "Oh, you
better stay on the tracks."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Because you're in the circle
in the square.
-Yeah.
-Which is --
The audience is around you.
-Yeah.
It's so easy to fall off
the train tracks.
As you know with "SNL"
and stuff --
-You got to be focused.
-You got to be focused live.
-Yeah, no,
I never broke character.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I was --
-You never corpsed?
-No, I never corpsed.
-No, you never corpsed.
-But, see, I would be --
'Cause the crowd's
right up on you there,
I would be distracted by --
because because I've been
to many a play and someone
always next to me
with the coughing --
like a decent phlegmy cough.
-Totally.
-Wherever I go, whatever night,
they're like --
[ Imitating cough ]
I go, "Wow!"
-You think they have
tuberculosis.
-I want them to go on stage.
Show me the dying scene.
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating cough ]
-Thank God they have masks now.
-I know.
-It makes sense.
There was a guy sleeping
in the front row the other day.
I said to Fishburne,
"You see that, Laurence?
The guy was out there sleeping
in the front row."
-Isn't that unbelievable?
-[ Snores ]
-It's dark, it's warm.
-Yeah.
-Right? And you're like,
"I'm in a good spot right now."
-In the front row!
The balls on the guy.
-What in the world?
This guy got tickets
to go see great actors --
-I got pretty loud, though.
I tried to wake him up.
I got a little loud.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
That's what I would do, too.
Also project a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Spit, project.
-Yeah, a little spit take.
"What?"
[ Spits ]
-A little anger.
-"Yeah, sorry to wake you up
from your nap there, buddy.
Gosh."
-We're just
doing a little show here.
-"Not a big deal, yeah.
We just worked
two years on this!
Sorry, buddy, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
"American Buffalo"
right now on Broadway.
I want to talk about
"The Bad Guys"
more after the break.
Come on back.
More with Sam Rockwell,
everybody.